grab your cleaning supplies and hide
your relics apple has a new Sci-Fi
mystery and I gotta say I was blown away
by the first two episodes with fantastic
performances by David oyelowo and
Rashida Jones combined with a fully
realized world I'm praying this show can
maintain its quality and become the new
Sci-Fi mystery hit I've been begging for
for those of you who are familiar with
my channel I often do deep Dives on
different shows but I'm shaking things
up and this is going to be a little
different than my traditional breakdowns
instead of a recap this is going to
focus solely on the different theories
Clues and Mysteries I've also left time
stamps below so you can see all the
topics I'll be discussing Silo is based
off a series of books which I haven't
read so there won't be any spoilers
there so any theories that emerge are
based solely off the show and not the
books Let's get ready to go outside in
episode 1 before Sheriff Becker arrests
himself for saying he wants to go
outside we see him preparing his room
knowing that he'll never be back one
such prep operation involves unscrewing
the panel to the ventilation shaft we
never see why he does this but my guess
to hide the hard drive and papers which
came into his possession in episode 2.
the same hard drive which led his wife
to go outside it can be assumed that if
Becker gets his wish and Juliet Nichols
becomes the next Sheriff she'll get his
apartment which would put her in a prime
spot to discover this drive but how will
she know to look into the vent in the
sheriff's office he leaves a note which
states double the flowers in front of
the mirror this is a reference to the
flowers in his apartment and since
Juliet may be the next Sheriff suggests
this note could be for her perhaps the
note is some sort of code word that will
lead Juliet to find whatever is in the
vent part of the main mystery of the
show is what exactly lies Outside The
Silo Allison so believes that the powers
that be are hiding the truth that she
sacrifices herself to find out what
happens two years later her husband will
do the same thing the judicial would
have us believe the outside is poisonous
those who go out to clean the sensor on
the video camera last roughly three
minutes before they collapse and die
before she sent out Allison said she'd
clean the sensor if what she saw was
beautiful in green and that's exactly
what she does but it's only when Becker
goes out that we see what he sees the
landscape is totally different than what
The Silo dwellers see on their screen so
we can't take anything we see here at
face value what the Dwellers see could
be digitally manipulated but this also
means what Becker sees could be too what
if this helmet is just a screen as well
something devised to encourage him to
clean the sensor after all Becker did
mention that historically almost those
who were sent outside to clean claimed
they would not do it yet they all do
Becker also takes off his helmet which
this one lady makes a really interesting
remark stating has anyone ever done that
before notice how Becker's POV you can't
see his wife's dead body but the crowd
can see it it's only when he takes off
his helmet that he crawls toward his
dead wife this would suggest that when
he's wearing that helmet he's seeing a
lie and only when his helmet is off does
he see the truth but the most damning
piece of evidence comes when Allison
finds a file on the hard drive called
Jane Carmody cleaning this is a video
file from Silo year 97 and we only see
it through the reflection on her glasses
but if you line it up with what Becker
sees it's the same exact video meaning
that what Becker sees is the same thing
Jane Carmody saw decades ago this would
suggest that every cleaner is given the
same fabricated video in an effort to
get them to clean the big question of
the show is what is The Silo and that's
probably the main mystery that will
likely spur the entire series all we
know is that it's a giant 140 floor plus
Mega structure dug deep into the Earth
to protect Humanity from the poison of
the outside world at least that's what
the judicial would want you to believe
we don't know much about these guys but
they seem to pull all the strings in
Silo and want to maintain the status quo
we really don't know anything about what
lies Beyond The Silo for all we know we
could be in space on another planet in
the far future or past watching a
sadistic experiment or this could all be
a simulation regardless this is the main
mystery I'll be looking for Clues on as
the season progresses perhaps the most
important item in the first two episodes
is this mysterious hard drive all we
know from George is that it was found
under a carpet in someone's closet we
the viewer don't get to see much of
what's on it in fact Allison and George
spend an entire day combing through it
and still have a lot more to go I've
already mentioned that Jane Carmody
cleaning video in my what's outside
section so the other important info we
get here are the blueprints of The Silo
itself primarily the existence of a
secret tunnel buried beneath the
concrete slab at the bottom of the silo
this is what George was going to explore
in episode 2 and where we leave Juliet
at at the end of the the episode and
while we're at it if you're lucky the
content so far and want me to continue
doing Silo videos please be sure to like
And subscribe two years after Allison's
death George's body is found having
fallen off the rails on the 120th floor
his girlfriend Juliet believes it to be
murder and from what we know it's likely
this has something to do with his
exploits underneath the giant digging
device remember that George found the
blueprints to The Silo plus who knows
what else he found on that hard drive he
also promised to Juliet not to tell her
if he went on that Dangerous Mission In
Search of the secret tunnel later
writing her a note saying he found what
he was looking for so it's entirely
possible he already made his way down
there and found out what was beyond it's
highly likely considering what George
was investigating that he was murdered
and if I were to guess who it was likely
this member of the judicial Sims the one
scene we see him in has absolutely no
relevance to the plot you could take it
out entirely and it wouldn't change
anything so I think this was shoehorned
in there to give us a little preview 140
years ago The Silo had its own Civil War
which pitted the rebels against the
founders the founders wound up
Victorious but in the process the rebels
destroyed hard drives burned books in
pretty much anything that happened
before this date or at least that's what
the powers that be would want you to
believe any quote-unquote Relic from the
before times is considered contraband in
possession of such items will get you
sent down to the mines my guess it
wasn't the rebels that erased this
history it was the founders and they
could rewrite history to make them look
like the heroes and did anyone else find
it weird that the moment they regained
their freedom was the 6 minute and six
second past six o'clock AKA 666
coincidence one of the interesting
things I noticed was when mayor Ruth
looks at these past mayoral ledgers
these books indicate important events in
Silo's history she tells Deputy marnes
that she's worked her way up to Silo
year 97 which coincidentally is the same
year of the Jane Carmody cleaning video
now here's where it it's even more
interesting if you stop the frame right
before she flips the page you can make
out September 13th year 97 and yes there
we see Jane Carmody cleaning from what I
can make out are the words successfully
completed and something that looks like
the phrase unexplained Beyond normal CD
levels now if you're better at
deciphering cursive than I am please let
me know what you think it says in the
comments there's not much we know about
the judicial which seems to be the most
powerful entity in Silo according to
Allison there's a conspiracy that they
never removed her birth control in the
first place since it's in the judicial's
best interest to have obedient dwellers
and not ones like her who ask questions
The Pact seems to be the governing body
of rules that both the judicial and
Sheriff's Office enforce in episode 1
the mayor reminds Becker that The Pact
allows for a hearing if someone is
misheard stating they want to go outside
but in Allison's case since so many
people heard it it won't be possible and
what's next for Julia yet the last we
see of her she's hanging from a rope
over the water pit beneath the digging
machine my guess is that this attempt
will be in vain and the door leading to
this tunnel if she even gets to see it
is either locked or buried under the
water in which case she'll need to go
back up top and find another way to open
it narratively I also think she'll end
up as sheriff or at least that's what I
think the writers have started to set up
he would also give her more power in
uncovering the mystery of Silo there is
also the mystery of this video camera
will she be able to get it to work and
if so what will she find but now I want
to turn it over to you I want to hear
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching
please be sure to like And subscribe and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember